I see you quite a lot at school our kids
go to the same school yes for the
athletically gifted children sprite my
kids are not but anyway they got it from
me but no we went we go to the same
school so I see you at school events yes
that's right
flipping pancakes we saw I actually
tweeted a photo of you and I flipping
pancakes they have us yeah set it up
they get us in there early in the
morning to flip pancakes kids on certain
days and you said can I tweet a picture
of this so I think that's a dandy by the
way yeah there you ask permission so
yeah then you can tell who it is yeah
let me say something about that picture
I showed that picture to Andy today and
he said I look so high I'm not I I I'm
not I just got up at like 5:00 in the
morning flip pancakes and I don't know
if it's the batter or what hangover for
yeah that's a that's from our school but
it's funny there's there are other like
there's there's some iconic stars in
there that we see some teachers whipping
pancake sometimes well you tell I'm not
gonna get in trouble with him I made a
movie with him okay oh my god Buchan
okay well Harrison Ford yeah and it's
crazy cuz you're there in the morning
you're flipping pancakes and all of a
sudden you feel a presence behind you
yes and you look over and it's Indiana
Jones with a flippin pancake and he's
looking at you with that sort of get off
my plane on Air Force One wait for my
griddle yeah he's looking at my pancakes
he's like you call those pancakes very
competitive yes a whip and hit5 he's
he's a very you know like you see him in
the movies he's kind of that way I mean
it's the coolest guy he is I've been in
helicopters that he's flown actually for
real he has flown you and a hello me in
his helicopter to set on several
occasions and it's at first it's quite
flattering and then you start to realize
there's controls in front of me and I
don't know what to do if anything
happens to him yeah and also he's a
great pilot apparently but I would use
these but I don't know if
oh yeah I'll know if he could really
land a plane with Anne Heche in a in a
in a storm isn't that what happened six
days seven nights rent it hit the button
thank you not in nor did I see ya
I'm trying to reference yeah and let's
give it up for Glenn Frey as well it's
also
Brandee screams did you see how dirty
the that was that wasn't that was it we
just got that out of the audience oh
really
either somebody's using it as a phone
and this is too much moisturizer no
someone's clearly frying chicken on that
spring it's an app but you know it's so
cool like he's I just think of him as a
kid and I was in some and Star Wars and
then you see him yes and I'm Chewbacca
next to him flying and and I said what
do I do in case he says if I die you die
so just sit back yeah
comforting things fun school we go